tout le monde connaît cette magnifique
carte postale avec 350 mille visites par
an le piton de la fournaise est un
hotspot patrimoniales ainsi son gîte du
volcan créé en 1962 mérité une
rénovation
[Musique]
tous les médias locaux étaient présents
pour le lancement de ce projet un projet
partenarial qui a nécessité de nombreux
mois de concertation afin de prendre en
compte tous les aspects de cet éco
construction accessible à tous et
notamment aux personnes à mobilité
réduite les exigences ont beaucoup
évolué depuis 50 ans que les gîtes
existe la structure était vraiment plus
adapté et on a vraiment commencé ce
projet par écouter les besoins des
touristes des acteurs qui représentait
le secteur touristique pour en gros
c'était vraiment améliorer le confort ça
a été le maître mot pour l'usager on a
voulu essayer aussi c'est de montrer que
les usages doivent changer et que même
si on est sur un milieu naturel avec du
confort on a veillé à avoir de
l'autonomie énergétique
on veut vraiment communiquer avec les
les futures
d'honneur les usagers sur le fait que
avoir un hébergement milieu naturel ça
veut dire aussi regarder sa consommation
énergétique sa consommation en eau en
offre la possibilité d'avoir des douches
mais ce sera avec des minuteurs avec on
compose en fait avec ce que la nature
nous offre un bâtiment totalement
intégré dans le paysage qui prend comme
modèle la lave cordes et on vient pas en
rupture mais on revient bien en
adaptation maximal pour se fondre au
mieux sur ce saut ces sites est donc un
projet qui devrait être bien intégré
tant dans le paysage lointain que dans
le paysage proches et l'expérience elle
sera j'espère unique aussi puisque
chaque chambre aura le même niveau 2
de confort ce terme de vue toutes les
chambres ont une vue sur le grand
paysage après la création d'une route
d'interprétation des caldera en 2013 ce
projet s'inscrit dans une dynamique
pluriannuel de rénovation des gîtes
départementaux 9,4 millions d'euros
seront investis pour cette
réhabilitation qui va mobiliser une
trentaine d'entreprises localement et
grâce à un phasage du chantier
le gîte restera ouvert pendant toute la
durée des travaux
[Musique]
moi